[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem montag wie vom sport hat norbert
lehmann familie und das sind einige
unserer themen heute
kein rettungsanker in sicht den mv
werften in mecklenburg vorpommern geht
auch wegen corona das geld aus
1900 arbeitsplätze stehen auf dem spiel
risiko für europas frieden die usa und
russland sprechen in genf über den
konflikt an der ostgrenze der ukraine
und etappensieg für novak djokovic der
mutmaßlich ungeimpfte tennis star darf
sich laut gerichtsbeschluss vorerst in
australien aufhalten
eine der größten industriebetriebe in
mecklenburg vorpommern muss aufgeben die
mv werften haben insolvenz angemeldet
eigentümer und bundesregierung machen
sich gegenseitig dafür verantwortlich
dass keine lösung für eine weitere
finanzierung gefunden wurde
unklar ist wie es mit den rund 1900
mitarbeitern weitergeht und ob ein
riesiges kreuzfahrtschiff zu ende gebaut
wird die mv werften gehören einem
asiatischen kreuzfahrtkonzern ihre
pleite steht für die krise einer ganzen
branche im vergangenen jahr gingen etwa
jeder vierte arbeitsplatz verloren im
moment sind noch rund 17.000 menschen an
werften beschäftigt anja cup -
ob das milliarden teure kreuzfahrtschiff
auf dem dock in wismar zu ende gebaut
werden kann durch die insolvenz der mv
westen fraglich die pandemie hatte den
eigener konzern gelting in finanznot
gebracht der bund wollte kurzfristig
durch den wirtschafts
stabilisierungsfonds für den weiterbau
600 millionen euro bereitstellen doch
nur unter einer bedingung es gibt klare
regeln für den wsf der sagt dass der
eigentümer sich auch beteiligen muss
normalerweise mit 20% wir hatten hier
eine forderung von 10% viele angebote
wochenlange verhandlungen doch genthin
ging auf die forderung des bundes nicht
ein und so muss die belegschaft weiter
um ausstehende löhne bangen und um die
eigene zukunft es ist nicht die erste
pleite die sie hier erleben ist
natürlich schwer für die region für
jeden einzelnen es ist belassen wir
gucken da vorne was soll's der
insolvenzverwalter muss nun übernehmen
an standorten in wismar rostock
stralsund und einer schwester werft in
bremerhaven hinter dem aktien konzern
genting steht der milliardär tanz viel
im kopf er wollte für seine reederei in
asien im nordosten erstmals eigene
kreuzfahrtschiff erbauen mit 301
millionen euro bürgt das land bereits
für die mva werften und erwartete vom
eigner eine beteiligung aus seinem
privatvermögen
deshalb ist es für die landesregierung
völlig unverständlich warum beginnt im
konzern hinter dem bekanntlich auch ein
finanzstarker eigentümer steht nicht
bereit war dieses deutliche bekenntnis
zu den eigenen werken abzugeben lenting
wollte sich heute in wismar vor der
presse nicht äußern die hoffnung hier
bleibt dass die maritime industrie eine
zukunft hat
tja bernd mosebach an der werft in
wismar wie groß ist die chance wie groß
ist die hoffnung dass da doch noch eine
lösung gefunden wird
das war erstmal natürlich ein
paukenschlag heute denn mit den
mitarbeitern die in den letzten monaten
hier stand frei gestellt wurden und
denen heute ist fast jeder zweite
arbeitsplatz im schiffbau in mecklenburg
vorpommern hier betroffen und der den
schiffbau ist hier das industrielle
rückgrat hat dieses landes ja die
hoffnung stirbt zuletzt war das motto
der letzten monate hier und das geht
auch so weiter die spätschicht wurde
hier heute erst mal abgesagt zum morgen
früh die frühschicht darf wieder
antreten bis auf die leiharbeiter die
wurden erst mal für längere zeit nach
hause geschickt das sind die ersten
opfer dieser insolvenz entscheidung und
dann soll weiter verhandelt werden der
entscheidende unterschied zu gestern ist
dass es seit heute oder in den nächsten
tagen einen insolvenzverwalter als
ansprechpartner geben wird damit muss
der bund und land nicht mehr mit der gm
spitze sprechen was sie am schluss doch
sehr schwierig war sondern ein neuer
partner und alle haben das interesse
dieses mega riesen milliarden kreuzfahrt
projekt dann zu ende zu bringen
zumindest dieses schiff und dann ende
des jahres auch tatsächlich auszuliefern
dankeschön nach wismar bernd mosebach
eine wichtige woche für die sicherheit
europas hat begonnen heute in genf
übermorgen in brüssel und am donnerstag
in wien werden diplomaten versuchen die
spannungen zwischen russland und dem
westen zu entschärfen europäer und die
usa fürchten dass russland einen
einmarsch in die ukraine platz bevor wir
zu den gesprächen kommen zeigt alexandra
vacano warum
panzer und noch mehr panzer rollen vor
ein paar tagen in richtung ukrainische
grenze auf den satellitenbildern
russische militärfahrzeuge seit einiger
zeit postiert russland nun zunehmend
soldaten nahe der ukrainischen grenze
nach angaben der usa seien inzwischen
schon 100.000 dort
hat sich auf jeden fall eine
realistische option geschaffen auch
militärisch in der krieg zu
interpretieren dafür spricht zum einen
jahr die masse an bildet er das material
was dort an der grenze stationiert
worden ist russland möchte die ukraine
als neutrale pufferzone zu den nato
staaten allerdings ist die ukraine seit
2008 zehn offiziell beitrittskandidat
der nato und dem hintergrund des
verlustes von 14 ich stehe eben für
wasserstelle handlungsbedarf und ja
diese unzufriedenheit dieser
handlungsbedarf ist das was die aktuelle
situation
fröhlich macht russische gefechts
übungen an der grenze zur ukraine im
dezember der konflikt so brisant wie nie
heute also der auftakt der
krisengespräche zwischen russland und
den usa auf neutralem boden in gent die
amerikaner fordern einen rückzug der
russischen truppen aus gaza gegen
verlangt unter anderem zusicherungen
dass die nato sich nicht weiter nach
osten ausdehnt für bürger
man habe den usa mitgeteilt dass es
keinen grund gebe eine eskalation zu
fürchten sagt russlands
vizeaußenminister am abend in genf aber
es sei besser einen schritt auf moskau
zu gehen
ich würde es hassen in eine situation zu
kommen in der die nato und die usa einen
fehler machen und zum nachteil ihrer
eigenen sicherheit und der sicherheit
des gesamten europäischen kontinents
handeln
die russischen forderungen haben sie
erneut zurückgewiesen sagt vize
außenministerin schwimmen die nato werde
einen beitritt der ukraine nicht
kategorisch ausschließen
fast acht stunden dauerten die gespräche
in genf in kiew gab es schon im vorfeld
unmut dass amerika und russland heute
über die ukraine gesprochen haben ohne
die ukraine stört viele hier
die ukraine sollte bei diesem treffen
dabei sein es geht doch uns am meisten
an mehr als russland und die vereinigten
staaten
ich denke den beiden geht es darum eine
übereinkunft zwischen sich selbst zu
erzielen und die ukraine wird als
verhandlungsmasse benutzt
übermorgen gehen die
sicherheitsgespräche weiter zum ersten
mal seit zweieinhalb jahren wird der
russland nato rat tagen dann russland
und die usa erst danach will sich vize
außenminister rjabkow festlegen ob
weitere verhandlungen mit den usa aus
moskauer sicht sinn machen
fragen wir immer tee wissen in
washington war das heute ein erster
schritt in richtung entspannung
also manchmal muss man ja auch um
weiterzukommen erst einmal wissen was
man vom anderen zu halten hat und
gemessen daran war es ein erster schritt
aber deeskalation ist wirklich lange
nicht in sicht wir hatten vorhin
gelegenheit mit der stellvertretenden us
außenministerin sherman zu sprechen und
sie hat mir auf nachfrage bestätigt dass
offenbar riad kopf während dieser
gespräche die vertragsentwürfe auf den
tisch gelegt hat zitiert hat aus ihnen
deren unterzeichnung russland ja von der
nato verlangt daran steht darin steht
nicht nur das eine mitgliedschaft von
ländern wie georgien oder ukraine
langfristig ausgeschlossen werden soll
sondern auch die forderung nato-truppen
aus nato-ländern wie zb denen im balkan
baltikum abzuziehen untersagen die
amerikanische seite ganz klar das kommt
überhaupt nicht in frage man hat
konkrete angebote gemacht zum beispiel
die stationierung von raketen aber auch
militärmanöver zu begrenzen allerdings
ist russland so hören wir jedenfalls aus
den verhandlungskreisen nicht bereit von
diesen maximalforderungen abzurücken und
das nährt hier die sorge in washington
dass man diese gespräche am ende dieser
woche vielleicht zum scheitern erklären
will um dann sie als grundlage dieses
scheitern als grundlage zu nutzen für
eine weitere eskalation in der ukraine
dankeschön für diese einschätzung emma
thompson aus washington war das
die linkspartei hat einen eigenen
kandidaten für die bundespräsidentenwahl
nominiert den sozialmediziner gerhard
trabert er soll im februar gegen frank
walter steinmeier antreten der mainzer
gerhard trabert kümmert sich seit
jahrzehnten um die medizinische
versorgung von obdachlosen und
flüchtlingen
er wurde vielfach ausgezeichnet unter
anderem mit dem bundesverdienstkreuz
jetzt zu corona und den aktuellen zahlen
an diesem montag nach angaben des robert
koch instituts gab es 25
1255 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
das sind 6700 37 mehr als vor einer
woche
52 todesfälle kamen innerhalb eines
tages dazu die sieben tage inzidenz
steigt auf
375 7
eine entscheidende frage im ganzen
corona geschehen ist wie zuverlässig
sind eigentlich die schnelltests
gesundheitsminister lauterbach hatte das
paul ehrlich institut beauftragt eine
liste von tests vorzulegen die auch die
omikron variante gut erkennen ein erstes
ergebnis zeigt vier von fünf schaffen
dass nina kuschelten mit den details es
geht fix unkompliziert und sie geben
einem ein sicheres gefühl die
schnelltests
245 von ihnen hat das paul ehrlich
institut getestet 80 prozent erfüllen
die geforderten kriterien können auch
die omikron variante sicher nachweisen
46 produkte allerdings nicht für den
präsidenten des instituts kein grund zur
besorgnis
es haben sich die länder die gekauft
haben für die beauftragten testzentren
andere zentren aber auch die discounter
an diesen listen orientiert und haben
die tests angeboten die tatsächlich von
uns positiv evaluiert wurden woran aber
liegt es dass es so einen enorm
qualitätsunterschied bei den tests gibt
1 punkt die zulassungsregeln es ist
wirklich erstaunlich aber fakt aktuell
sind es die hersteller selbst die
qualität ihrer produkte überprüfen um
dann ein ce siegel und damit die
zulassung zum europäischen markt das ist
ganz klar eine kontrolle die wird jetzt
ende mai geschlossen dann werden
unabhängige labore diese überprüfung
übernehmen dann aber eben auch erst dann
könnten unzulässige und unzuverlässige
produkte vom markt genommen werden den
verbrauchern bleibt bis dahin nur der
blick auf die testergebnisse und selbst
daran gibt es kritik bislang sind erst
rund ein drittel der tests die auf dem
markt sind überhaupt überprüft worden
und die die getestet wurden sind sehr
unterschiedlich in ihrer qualität einige
schlagen zum beispiel erst bei einer
sehr hohen virenlast an was wir brauchen
ist eine klare abstufung dass man auch
auf einen ersten blick erkennen kann
welches sind in die wirklich guten tests
die sicherste variante bleibt der pcr
test dieser ist kostenlos bei einer
roten warnmeldung in der korona app oder
einem positiven schnelltest
in acht weiteren bundesländern gingen
heute die schule wieder los damit sind
die weihnachtsferien im ganzen land
vorbei die große frage ist und bleibt
wie können die schulen trotz nikon offen
bleiben für viele schülerinnen und
schüler stand erstmal ein test auf dem
programm
johanna kösler berichtet
die türen der leonore goldschmidt schule
in hannover sind wieder auf die schüler
erst mal froh sie hoffen dass es nicht
wieder zu schließungen und quarantäne
kommt gegen online wäre ich jetzt auch
nicht unbedingt abgeneigt aber
präsent ist halt immer besser so sieht
man übrigens alle leute wieder und auch
wenn die zahlen wieder hoch sind meint
es sich auf meine ist ja auch wurst als
kämpft von da ist setze ich noch nie so
schlimm also ich hätte mir ein paar
weitreichendere regeln schon auch das
ist ein klares und fiel hin und her in
thüringen etwa blieben die schulen
kurzfristig zwei tage länger zu das
mussten vor allem die familien abfangen
wenn man versucht so viele dinge
parallel zu machen dann macht man alles
ein bisschen und nicht richtig als der
erste locker und war da habe ich dann
ganz viel in den abendstunden noch
gesessen und gab und da war ich sehr
dankbar dass ich einen teilzeitjob habe
mit vollzeitjob ist das unvorstellbar
eine belastung für arbeitende eltern
aber auch für die schüler wenn sie zu
hause bleiben bekommen sie teils weniger
lernstoff und sind mehr auf sich allein
gestellt um lern rückstände und
psychische folgen zu vermeiden wollen
die kultusminister alles tun um die
schulen diesmal offen zu halten ich gehe
davon aus dass es keine flächendeckenden
schulschließungen geben wird sondern
allenfalls punktuell oder regional
soweit das infektionsgeschehen das
erfordern wird viel testen masken und
hygieneregeln das ist die derzeitige
strategie damit der präsenzunterricht
trotz omikron stattfinden kann gefüge
in italien gelten von heute an
verschärfte corona regeln und eine
impfpflicht für über 50 jährige dort
hatte sich die lage zuletzt deutlich
verschärft vor vier wochen lagen in
italien die täglichen neuinfektionen bei
rund 20.000 anfang januar dann ihre core
zahl von über 200.000 fällen innerhalb
eines tages jetzt sind es noch über
100.000 andreas postel hat details ein
negativer test allein reicht nicht mehr
aus einem skilift von igor mazzola in
den dolomiten hier gilt ab jetzt zweig
nur wer geimpft oder genesen ist kommt
auf die piste der super green passt kein
problem ich denke die leute schweren es
auch schätzen weil super g das heißt
vielleicht sichere schiefern sicheres
gondel fahren und deswegen könnte sein
dass es auch vielleicht ein plus ist ein
plus vor allem für geimpfte von gröden
bis palermo italien weit gilt ab jetzt
der zweig standard auch im außenbereich
von restaurants in hotels im nahverkehr
und auf fähren deutsche touristen können
die qr-codes ihrer impfnachweis
verwenden die bisherigen maßnahmen
reichten offenbar nicht aus um den
rasanten anstieg der infektionszahlen in
italien zu verhindern trotzdem sind auf
den intensivstationen landesweit bislang
weniger als 2.000 betten belegt damit
das auch so bleibt führt italien die
impfpflicht ab 50 ein
nachdem wir in italien bereits zu zwei
gegner auf die gesamte arbeitswelt
ausgedehnt haben machen wir nun für alle
die älter als 50 jahre alt sind das
impfen zur pflicht
während deutschland noch zögert handelt
italien eine impfpflicht für über
50-jährige entspringt dabei einerseits
der erfahrung dass ältere menschen
bisher schwerer an kuwait 19 erkrankten
andererseits und auch das gehört zur
wahrheit war die einführung einer
allgemeinen impfpflicht in der
regierungskoalition von mario draghi in
rom schlichtweg nicht durchsetzbar wegen
viele ansteckungen fehle bereits jetzt
in vielen bereichen das personal und
dabei ist der gipfel der omicron welle
auch in italien noch nicht erreicht
new york trauert um die opfer eines der
schwersten brände dort in den letzten
jahren 17 menschen starben in einem
wohnhaus das feuer brach in einem der
unteren stockwerke aus zwar konnte es in
relativ kurzer zeit gelöscht werden da
hat er sich aber bereits tödlicher rauch
überall im gebäude verteilt auch acht
kinder kamen ums leben
brandursache ist offenbar ein kaputtes
heizgerät
das hin und her um die einreise des
serbischen tennis stars novak djokovic
nach australien wird mehr und mehr zum
politikum aber das ist der neueste stand
der hat heute vor einem australischen
gericht zumindest einen juristischen
teilerfolg erzielt er darf in melbourne
bleiben und dort auch trainieren ob er
aber an den australian open teilnehmen
darf das bleibt offen seine anhänger
jedenfalls feiern in serbien und auch in
australien
die serbischen fans in melbourne jubeln
als djokovic das erste match schon
gewonnen in diesem turnier dabei war es
erst die juristische vorrunde ich bin
erfreut und dankbar schreibt der
tennis-star heute ich will bleiben und
antreten das foto zeigt ihn schon beim
training mehrere tage saß sie in diesem
abschiebe hotel fest so sehen dort die
zimmer aus und so zuweilen das menü der
streit ging darum ob djokovic ungeimpfte
in australien einreisen darf die
serbische heimat tage lang in kollektive
empörung entflammt die familie in
aufruhr das ganze weitet sich zu die
affäre als sie schließlich sogar der
präsident ein schaltet er ist im
vorwahlkampf und weiß wenn es um
nationalhelden geht versteht serbien
keinen spaß
familie djokovic hatte die anhörung am
morgen verfolgt und zeigte sich danach
hocherfreut
ich danke dem richter dafür wie er
diesen prozess geführt hat und dass er
der welt die ganze wahrheit gezeigt hat
nichts als die wahrheit
doch es gibt widersprüche djokovic
anwalt hatte argumentiert djokovic sei
am 16 dezember corona positiv getestet
worden fraglich nur weshalb er
offensichtlich einen tag später diesen
öffentlichen termin waren nahmen morgen
entscheidet der einwanderungsminister ob
djokovic den traum von einem zehnten
titel in möbeln angehen darf
gelungene generalprobe die deutschen
handballer gewannen gestern abend in
wetzlar gegen olympiasieger und rekord
weltmeister frankreich knapp mit 35 zu
34 das macht hoffnung für die am
donnerstag beginnende em in ungarn und
der slowakei
sehr gut für das selbstvertrauen der
sieg der unerfahrenen mannschaft mit
gleich neun em debütanten
optimierungsbedarf gibt es aber noch in
der defensive und in sachen
konzentration
[Musik]
das ist trotzdem klappt liegt vor allem
an routinier kai häfner der acht mal
trifft und armut des jungen luca witzke
der in den schlusssekunden das 35 zu 34
erzielt
positiv auch die schulterverletzung die
sich spielmacher philipp weber zuzieht
ist nicht schwer von weber ist der satz
überliefert wir sind die wundertüte des
turniers
und das erste spiel der deutschen
handballer am freitag in belarus data
miner apropos wundertüte nach einer
frostigen nacht bekommen wir morgen
ruhiges wetter die details hat gleich
ist intern christian sievers freut sich
auf sie im heute journal um viertel vor
zehn wir freuen uns wenn sie morgen
wieder dabei sind danke für ihr
interesse einen schönen abend noch und
alles gute ihnen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
beamte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter eine umfangreiche hochdruckbrücke
hat sich ausgebildet und zwar vom
atlantik über mitteleuropa bis nach
russland und bringt durchaus
sonnenschein aber teilweise auch
kompakte wolken in der nacht gibt es im
süden dichte wolken und hier schneit es
noch etwas es lässt aber dann bald nach
dessen klart es teilweise auf und auch
nach osten hin in der mitte gibt es
dichte wolken dort wo es aufklart wird
es eisig kalt vor allem nach osten bis
minus 6 grad im westen minus fünf und
knapp 2 grad in der mitte deutschlands
da wo die wolken kompakter sind morgen
tagesverlauf viel sonne im osten und
auch im westen sonst dürften auch
dichtere wolkenfelder durch und die
temperaturen erreichen höchstwerte von
minus zwei grad im osten hier also
dauerfrost den ganzen tag ähnlich am
alpenrand 6 grad mild wird es dann
richtung rhein main gebiet und die
nächsten tage gibt es durchaus für
sonnenschein am mittwoch im süden und
der nimmt dann am donnerstag sogar noch
weiter zu temperaturen ändern sich kaum
liegen zwischen minus zwei und plus 9
grad damit ein schöner abend